les résultats viennent de tomber
la liste citoyenne d'opposition à sa
tête bertrand vos remporte la mairie de
tournus avec presque 62 % des voix
un seul tour aura donc suffi pour
convaincre
j'en ai pas prévu parce que je pensais
pas que ça pourrait passer au premier
tour comme ça donc c'est très émouvant
c'est ces va et ce qui nous intéresse
par dessus tout j'ai de rétablir le
dialogue et la confiance entre les
électeurs et les élus et de rétablir
aussi l'action dans la réalisation des
projets pour les tournusiens c'est la
fin d'un feuilleton politique en juillet
dernier 12 conseillers municipaux
avaient présenté leur démission
les projets du maire ne faisait plus
l'unanimité suis ravie soulagé que la
démocratie est le
reviennent un petit peu en force sur un
tournus et je pense qu'il ya du lieu qui
va se remettre entre les habitants ont
tourné une page peu connue
j'espère que voilà la situation va
s'apaiser en ville et que on va pouvoir
mener des projets à l'échelle de notre
ville justement est pas du projet
surdimensionné
christian bernard ancien adjoint au
maire ne recueille que 15 % des voix
mais pour lui ce n'est qu'une semi
défaite nous avons fait la moitié notre
job
nous avons éliminé le maire en place
claude roche qui nous a floués tout le
temps de la participation que nous avons
le temps que nous avons donné pendant
son mandat
quant au maire sortant il compte bien
rester dans l'opposition
ces trois ans ne sera observateurs
on sera plus à gdansk observateurs mais
on ne manquera pas de réagir
chaque fois cela sera difficile le
nouveau maire de tournus prendra ses
fonctions en fin de semaine